♪ ♪
>> Greg: TUESDAY THE VIOLENT
GROUP ANTIFA TWEETED OUT
IDENTITIES AND LOCATIONS OF OVER
1500 IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
AGENTS.
THIS IS CALLED DOXSING.
CLEARLY, -- ARE YOU SURPRISED?
NOT WHEN THE MEDIA'S LOUDEST
VOICES DESCRIBED AMERICA AS THE
THIRD REICH, MAKING AGENTS
STORMTROOPERS.
SO LADONNA BRIAN TWEETED I GUESS
WE PUT TO REST THE QUESTION,
NAZI GERMANY, COULD IT HAPPEN IN
AMERICA.
ON TWITTER, ACTOR PETER FONDA
INSTRUCTED THE WORLD TO TARGET
THE AGENTS BY SURROUNDING KIDS
SCHOOLS AND SCARING THE F OUT OF
THEM.
FONDA ALSO CALLED FOR KIDNAPPING
BARRON TRUMP TO BE PUT IN A CAGE
WITH PEDOPHILES.
THAT TWEET GOT OVER 1,000 LEGS.
ALSO CALLED FOR KIRSTJEN NIELSEN
TO BE STRIPPED NAKED AND
WHIPPED.
OUTRAGE MINUS ANY SOLUTION
CREATES A BLOOD THIRST TARGETING
AMERICANS TRYING TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT THE LOUDEST VOICES
NEVER CARED ABOUT UNTIL NOW.
A SIMPLE GOOGLE SEARCH WILL FIND
TERRIBLE TALES OF CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING.
IS THAT THE ALTERNATIVE YOU
WOULD WANT FOR 125,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHO'VE COME
TO AMERICA SINCE 2011 FROM
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR.
I GOT THAT STAT FOR
"WASHINGTON POST" 2016 ARTICLE
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN
CHARGE BACK WHEN PETER FONDA AND
THE REST DIDN'T SEEM TO MIND.
SINCE I WROTE THAT BEAUTIFUL
MONOLOGUE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
AMERICA, PETER FONDA HAS SINCE
APOLOGIZED, CLAIMING -- ABOUT
THE BARRON TRUMP THING, I WENT
TOO FAR.
IT WAS WRONG AND I SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE IT.
I BELIEVE HE ISSUED A AN APOLOGY
BECAUSE THE SECRET SERVICE
SERIES OF LAWS FOR A THREATENING
TWEET, THREATENING THE
PRESIDENT'S RELATIVE.
>> Jesse: ONE LEFT IS
COMPARING REPUBLICANS TO NAZIS
YET THEY ARE THE ONES FASCINATED
WITH BEHEADINGS AND CHILD RAPE.
JANE FONDA POSED ON THE TOP OF
NORTH VIETNAMESE TANKS AND PETER
SAID HOLD MY BEER.
WATCH WHAT I DO TO THE
PRESIDENT'S ON.
THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA, THEY
THREW A TANTRUM.
THEY THREW A TANTRUM, OFFERED NO
SOLUTIONS AND WHEN THE PERSON
CAME IN AND CREATED A SOLUTION,
THEY STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO ONTO THE
NEXT DISASTER AND TRY TO CALL
THE NEXT PERSON HITLER OR CALL
THE NEXT PERSON A NAZI.
DOESN'T MATTER WITH THIS
PRESIDENT DOES.
THEY DID WITH THE TRAVEL BAN.
THEY DID IT -- ALMOST EVERY
POLICY, HE HAS BEEN COMPARED TO
HITLER.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT'S GOING
>> Greg: THEY ELIMINATED ANY
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FOR
NORTH KOREA.
KIMBERLY, STRIKES ME STRANGE AS
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO RESENT
CALLING MS-13 ANIMALS HAVE NO
PROBLEM CALLING PEOPLE
STORMTROOPERS AND NAZIS.
>> Kimberly: THE PETER FONDA
ISSUE IS REPULSIVE,
REPREHENSIBLE.
I DON'T CARE THAT HE APOLOGIZED.
SORRY ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH, TO SAY
THAT A 12-YEAR-OLD BOY SHOULD BE
PUT IN A CAGE WITH PEDOPHILEs
HE COULD BE RAPED IS ABSOLUTELY
DISGUSTING.
I AM A MOTHER OF AN 11-YEAR-OLD.
FOR SOMEONE TO SAY THAT TO
HAPPEN TO A CHILD, IT'S REALLY
SICKENING WHEN YOU SEE THE LEVEL
OF THE DEPRAVITY OF LEFT AND
HOLLYWOOD WHEN THEY BEHAVE LIKE
THIS, TO THE POINT WHERE MELANIA
TRUMP HAD TO CALL SECRET SERVICE
TO MAKE SURE TO GET THIS
INVESTIGATED BECAUSE IT'S A REAL
THREAT.
WHEN PEOPLE SEE STUFF LIKE THIS,
IT'S DANGEROUS FOR A CHILD TO
SAY SOMETHING.
I HAVE THIS HAPPEN WHEN I HAD
PEOPLE, GOING VIRAL, I HAD THIS
WHOLE SNOOP DOGG AND BOW WOW
THING.
PEOPLE CAME AFTER MY SON WHO WAS
11 I DID THE SAME THING AND IT
WAS HORRIFIC.
IT HAS TO STOP AND IT'S GROSSLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY SOMEBODY
WOULD EVEN PUT A MOVIE OUT WITH
A GUY LIKE THIS IN IT.
HE SHOULD LITERALLY NEVER WORK
AGAIN.
>> Greg: THERE WILL BE PEOPLE
IN HOLLYWOOD WHO SEE HIM AS A
HERO.
HE MIGHT GET A TV SHOW OUT OF
IT.
HE IS STILL ON TWITTER?
>> Katie: I HAVEN'T CHECKED.
I DID NOTICE HE DELETED THEM.
>> Kimberly: UNDERNEATH THAT
THERE WERE OTHER CALLS FOR OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP FAMILY AND
CHILDREN, THEY WERE GOING TO
COME FOR THAT CHILD AND THAT'S
THE PROBLEM WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
THE PROBLEM WITH THE ENVIRONMEN
ENVIRONMENT, DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT.
>> Katie: IT IS THE INITIAL
STATEMENT HE MADE AND I THINK HE
MEANT THAT AND THEN THE MOB THAT
CAME TO BACK HIM UP ON THE
STATEMENT I THINK IS EVEN MORE
TERRIFYING THAN THE INITIAL
THING THAT HE SAID.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WAS PRAISED
ROMAN POLANSKI.
I'M NOT SURPRISED THIS WOULD BE
SOMETHING HE WOULD WANT TO SAY.
THIS DOESN'T BRING US ANY CLOSER
TO A REAL SOLUTION ABOUT
PEOPLE'S LIVES WHO ARE IN
DANGER, WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE IN
AMERICA WHOSE FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
RIPPED APART BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION CRIME OR PARENTS WHO
HAVE SENT THEIR CHILDREN TO THE
BORDER ON A HARROWING JOURNEY.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO GO.
ARE THEY GOING TO BE PUT INTO A
LABOR SITUATION WHERE THEY OWE A
SMUGGLER A LABOR DEBT, BECAUSE
THAT'S A REAL THING.
WE DON'T KNOW.
THIS KIND OF LANGUAGE IS
HORRIFIC.
IT'S AWFUL.
IT HAS REAL-LIFE CONSEQUENCES,
AND THEIR PEOPLE'S LIVES RIGHT
NOW TODAY WHO DEPEND ON REAL
SOLUTIONS COMING FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES, AND THIS GUY
ISN'T DOING ANYTHING BUT MAKING
THE SITUATION WORSE.
>> Greg: A JUAN, I'M NOT GOING
TO ASK YOU TO DEFEND IT.
I KNOW YOU FOUND IT DISGUSTING.
>> Juan: IT WAS A POORLY
WORDED TWEET, OFFENSIVE
LANGUAGE.
WHAT STRIKES ME FROM THIS VERY
CONVERSATION IS YOU GUYS, IT
TAKES AWAY.
YOU DELIGHT IN IT BECAUSE IT
TAKES AWAY FROM THE CONVERSATION
FOCUSING ON WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID THAT IS ANTITHETICAL TO
AMERICAN VALUES.
>> Greg: SO THAT JUSTIFIES --
>> Juan: SEPARATING A
4-YEAR-OLD.
IMAGINE THREE 4-YEAR-OLDS NOT
KNOWING WHERE HIS OR HER PARENTS
ARE.
DIVERTING.
>> Juan: THE ISSUE IS THE
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITY ACTING LIKE
A FULL.
THE FOOLISH THING IS PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THE PRESIDENT DID
SOMETHING HERE.
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
INDEPENDENTS, AND IT'S
ABHORRENT.
>> Greg: AND IT JUSTIFIES THIS
BEHAVIOR?
GOT IT.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY IT
JUSTIFIED IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE DEFINITELY
DEFENDING IT.
>> Juan: I SAID YOU ARE
DELIGHTING A BECAUSE IT GIVES
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY.
>> Jesse: THE LEFT WAS
DELIGHTING IN THIS STORY BECAUSE
IT DISTRACTS FROM THE IG AND THE
SINGAPORE SUMMIT.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS ABOUT THE
SAFETY AND PROTECTION OF
CHILDREN.
>> Juan: IT IS.
>> Kimberly: WHAT PETER FONDA
DID IS INDEFENSIBLE.
>> Juan: NOBODY IS DEFENDING
IT.
>> Kimberly: YOU SAID IT WAS
JUST POORLY WORDED.
CRIMINAL SEXUAL ACT BY A SEXUAL
PREDATOR.
>> Juan: YOU CHOOSE TO FOCUS
ON IT BECAUSE IT GETS YOU A